all right
I've been trying to give a lot of
thought recently about
how I can talk to you about
being enlightened
so many
people in the world not only doing
Aikido but martial arts in general
think that good technical
and Fitness
is all you need to be a good martial
artist
but Aikido out of martial arts that I
know and I don't know that many to be
honest
it seems to be an all-encompassing art
but more playing on the mind
than the technical
yes at first
um
I had two left feet
done everything wrong
and I've come
this year in September
2023 I should be celebrating 50 years of
Aikido
it sounds such a long time that I
actually wonder where it's gone 50 years
of it I mean it's
this is if I'm talking about someone
else rather than myself
what have I learned in those 50 years
not a lot really to be honest
um I might have been able to learn as
much in five years knocking off the zero
but all I can do is um tell you that
not everything is as clear and simple as
it may seem
most of the Aikido I watch on
uh YouTube
to me
isn't asens as I could
it's very poorly done
there's so many mistakes
you see Aikido is a multiple martial art
and yet I see most of these teachers
demonstrate us
showing their Aikido on one-to-ones
even when there's multiple people
around them they seem to concentrate
their new eyesight their view on the
person they're dealing with rather than
keeping a wide view
it's so easy to become the master
of the techniques
when you're a beginner
tend to stumble and spend all your time
trying to gather techniques do your best
as you go through the cue grades
you have all this fun while doing it
making all these mistakes
and
it's like a piece of wood that is cut
from the tree and you're slowly honing
it and shaping into something of your
choice
perhaps a bowl wooden Bowl perhaps you
know your
you're going to be
trying to carve out an object from it
whatever this plan that you more than
likely don't even know about as a a low
grade
starts to form a pathway
and I was talking to somebody recently
on the messenger
they're in their 50s
and I said oh yeah but the way you look
at Ikea now and the intensity you put
into it
is
um quite unusual
don't please don't think of yourself as
an average aikidoka because you're not
uh the the the foresight you have
and the questions do you ask are not the
usual questions
I'm saying that from somebody who has
got 50 years of listening to people's
questions watching the Aikido
but
even people who
become downgrade
second down third down this is in in my
opinion in the technical stages of
Aikido
the learning stages
of who we are how good we want to be our
views
of you are sometimes very strong views
we get very opinionated and this can
even last through the career of even the
Masters
I can't say what a seventh and 8th down
and Ninth then think about and how they
view things because I haven't reached
that
height
but what I do know is
a lot of people criticize and put down
Aikido
if it's thought of not as they think
if I could die
the opinionated person
because they see go speaking
I'm unsure about that
but just because it's not fitting there
yeah
their little box of thought
that
line of thinking then it can't be like
either it can't be martial
well I left behind
the Marshall side of Aikido a long time
ago
but I still know that when I started I
didn't start it to learn a martial art
started it because somebody talked me
into it and if you've got my book it'll
tell you in there why I started and how
it came about
to me Aikido must work as a martial art
but most of the techniques that are
performed won't work as a martial art
because they're too long
they have to be much shorter
and that's why when you watch Masters
such as go sociodo Sensei himself
toei sensei
search out these Old Masters watch their
films
um
Chiba Scentsy you know very direct very
powerful
Tada sensei in his 90s now
very strong-minded
but that they do movements that are very
short quick and it's over in a Flash and
this is where it should become
the art
no messing around just directly in to
suppress the attacker you haven't got
time for this beauty and wonderful
techniques that we we do
techniques are there to hone you as a
person
the finished Bowl
is what you look for through the Q
grades the early down grades
to me once you become a fourth Dan if
you're still working on the technical
understanding and worrying about why you
can't get the technical correct
then you're not expanding your mind
you're not opening up your mind to view
others thoughts other ways of looking at
the heart if you haven't mastered the
techniques by Third Down
I doubt if you'll never Master them
if you think you've mastered them at
third down
because you can
demonstrate on all your students on a
demonstration
and you think you've found mastery
then you haven't opened your mind and
you need to open your mind
I hope these words have prick some
thoughts and I always talk more about
this
in detail in my next
uh offering thank you for your time